good morning hank it's tuesday what's a
five-star review that lives in your head
rent-free for me it's a review i read
many years ago of the 12-pack of purple
sharpies
so the reviewer gave the pack five stars
and wrote in the review that in their
monotonous work they often had to use
sharpies and found that using purple
ones brought a little bit of joy and
color to an
otherwise unbearably bland life i'm
really bad at remembering exact phrases
and i have never been able to find this
review since i read it for the first
time but that is the phrase as i
remember it a little bit of joy and
color in an otherwise unbearably bland
life
anyway i've been thinking about this
because today i've been signing with
purple sharpie in my quest to sign all
250 000 copies of the first printing of
the us edition of the anthropocene
reviewed book and it actually has
brought a bit of joy and color into my
life there's something about the
richness of the purple that really does
make repetition
somehow less repetitious like the first
hundred thousand or so signatures were
actually quite easy because it felt like
a break from the work of
writing the book which i found
exhausting at times and emotionally
draining in part because despite its
grandiose title the anthropocene
reviewed is a very personal book it's my
first attempt to like
write about my actual self now i want to
be careful not to imply that writing is
difficult work because i have done
difficult work and
writing is not it but for me at least it
does require like an intense level of
focus and concentration which can be a
little emotionally exhausting and this
time around because it was about me
it felt at times for better or worse
like my whole self was being poured into
the book which is a little terrifying so
anyway
signing was a break from that also
anyone who's been around here a while
knows how much i love a beautifully
foolish endeavor like i am completely
enamored with double agent the world of
warcraft player who plays the game as a
pacifist panda acquiring experience
points primarily via picking flowers
which he has done
literally millions of times to achieve
the highest rank in the game
i'm also a fan of kurt j mack who has
been walking in one direction
in minecraft for the last 10 years in
search of the farlands
and i also love artwork that involves a
lot of repetition and careful mark
making
like this piece by hiroyuki doi or this
one by robin o'neill
and when i make drawings i tend to do so
in an obsessive way like this drawing of
17 000 circles or actually
no circles 17 000 failed attempts at
circles i don't know why i'm drawn to
art as endurance efforts but whatever i
like them they
bring me joy oh but i can't let it go
with that because i have to hyper
analyze because that is my nature like
the art critic robert hughes wrote of
the peculiarly modernist hell of
repetition and i think i like work that
turns that on its head and finds
color and joy and repetition slightly
off topic but hugh's thinking that
repetition is a modern phenomenon
strongly implies to me that he never
attempted
agriculture because like if you think
that picking flowers in world of
warcraft is repetitious try
thinning row after row after row of
carrot seedlings
anyway the point is the first hundred
thousand or so signatures were easy and
now it has become
harder and i still have to sign for 300
hours and my hand hurts a little and
this is the part where a test of
endurance even an exceptionally silly
test of endurance actually becomes
a test like the book comes out in three
months and obviously it has to be
printed before that so there is not that
much time left in which to sign and
there are a lot of
marks left to make like i remember when
i signed 150 000 times for the fault in
our stars at the end i was signing like
12 or 14 hours a day and i would be
thinking oh i don't know if i can do
this and oh this is a lot and then
along would come the purple sharpie to
remind me
that i made this promise and i can keep
it sometimes
a bit of color and joy is enough hank
i'll be signing live on youtube for an
hour this afternoon i promise it'll be
very boring but
it will be purple the whole way link in
the doobly-doo
i will see you on friday oh ps as it
says on my 2021 vision board
here's to perseverance both the rover
and
the value hank thank you for making me a
fan of mars so i could
openly weep when that rover landed on
the red planet by the way
remember when like not scheduling
haircuts was my biggest
problem oh god remember when i thought
hair emergencies were emergencies i want
to go back in time and just like
pinch that little boy on his cheeks all
right now i'm really gonna go cause i
got a sign